où est-il petit petit petit petit petit
petit petit home et où se cache-t-il à
petit ou et kull mon trottoir petit
petit petit mais je ne te ferait pas mal
bon petit petit petit jolie vient du
passé
tu vu les ennemis petit j'espère qu'il
n'est pas devenu fille qui tient réseau
vous aurez une fermière en train de
chercher ses poulets et mieux c'est
encore de lui demander ce qu'il est en
train de faire et bien c'est nous on
voudrait te poser une question avec
julie harcelé quand vous merci ce n'est
peut-être pas la formule de politesse
idéal pour dire bonjour à quelqu'un
oh excusez moi tous les deux mecs je
croyais que c'était celui que je cherche
depuis près d'une heure et tu étais déçu
et qui peut seulement c'est déjà plus
gentil mais qui cherche t-il peut-être
pouvons-nous teddy a oui vous l'avez
peut-être vu mais qui cherchent qu à la
paix ils sortent de là d'un oui c'est un
lapin deux longues oreilles il a une
jolie petite forêt eu un et une mignonne
petite queue blanche d'un seul n'en dit
pas beaucoup plus sur l'espèce deux
tours la peur comment je voulais
pourtant décrit avec précision mais
casimir françois a raison
le gros ennuis ta description c'est que
tous les la pâte ou deux grandes
oreilles une jolie petite fourrure et
une jolie que blanc que sur évidemment
j'appelle quelques enfants
bien pour blancpain l'arrivée des quasi
mirabeau nouvian bbk pas casimir a perdu
à la fois
est ce que l'un de vous l'aurez vu non
alors là ça devient ça devient plus
grave parce que si personne ne l'a vu
c'est qu'il a déjà quitté le jardin
alors là là cet affront et a vu se
perdre dans le neuf une immense forêt où
ils risquent d'être dévorée par et des
affreuses bêtes sauvages où ils coûtent
15 humeur il n'existe aucune forêt de
séjourner dans les douches enfants ah
c'est vrai mais alors ouais mon lapin
une seconde casimir nous allons essayer
de trouver de quelle espèce de lapin il
s'agit des enfants vous connaissez des
espèces de la paix quelles espèces
[Musique]
lapins sauvages qui s'appelle le lapin
de garenne le lièvre c'est de la même
famille le lapin de garenne vie en
liberté dans l'écrit ou dans les bois il
y aussi des la sphère domestique
bc oui au plan tonnerre puisque à clapet
domestique l'appartement ils sont l
couleurs des lapins d'appartements
général honneur un lapin se fera dans un
appartement c'est à la campagne il ya
des lapins domestiques
l'un parlant qui s'appelle le fauve de
bourgogne qui est un gros la peur ou est
aussi le la peur risque est à la peine
tout blanc il est poignant et a les yeux
de quelques couleurs jeu la paire russe
des ae rouge rouge alors casimir alors
quoi eh bien là alors de quelle race et
ton lapin je n'en sais rien moi je n'ai
jamais vu cette fois j'y comprends plus
rien
enfin casimir tu ne peux pas procéder à
la fin tu n'as jamais vu
c'est un cadeau de mon oncle archibald
chat prenant garde sur la lettre julie
jeu comprendra mon cher casimir qu'est
ce qui t'arrive ça t'arrive
je crois qu'elle est devenue
complètement folle et julie calme-toi
déjà quasi regarde ce que les longueurs
sibal mon cher casimir jeter posé un
lapin
maintenant on peut les unir
tu n'as jamais eu aucun la peur et
comment au look archibald mot l'écrit
sur la lettre a tant qu'ingénieur je
vais t'expliquer tu avais un rendez vous
avec ton oncle archibald et il n'est pas
venu comme eco commencé qu est ce que tu
as écrit justement pour s'excuser de son
absence mais non par la lettre ils ne
parlent pas justement du rendez vous
manqués ne parle que du lapin et écoute
casimir si longue archibald avait
réellement apporté à la planète aura
écrit jeter des posé un lapin mais
l'expression posé un lapin à une autre
signification vous la connaissez et vous
ça veut dire poser à la classe avez vous
posé un lapin ça veut dire ne pas venir
un rendez vous sans prévenir l'autre
j'étais comme moi une autre ça dépend
oui alors je n'ai même pas un petit
lapin et nous résigner infos que je ne
sois pas très bien je crois qu'il me
reste encore une loge de dire son nom
pas très bien non mais attends geely
d'abord il faut que j'écrive à mon oncle
archibald pour lui donner un autre
rendez vous tu as raison le facteur ne
va pas tarder à faire sa tournée entamée
à temps il ne me reste que ce petit
crayon au long mais ça c'est beaucoup
trop petit pour moi je ne peux pas
écrire avec ça mais tu n'as qu'à me
dictait sa lettre je te l'écrire
non merci je lis tu es vraiment gentille
voilà vas-y quand tu veux alors cher
oncle archibald
sherbrooke la finale j'ai reçu la lettre
du latin je te donne rendez vous demain
à midi signé casimir ça ira tu ne lui
mets aucune formule de politesse
ah non non pas de formules de politesse
pour l'autre archibald ont fait il faut
toujours une formule de politesse
casimir tu peux lui dire je t embrasse
bien fort n'ont pas de formules de
politesse nous fait ainsi mire quelque
chose de plus simple alors bien at war
non non non pas question enfin ch'ti pas
de formules pour archibald mais quasi
virtuel vraiment trop rancunier
ce n'est pas parce que tous n'ont que
l'archipel pas posé un lapin que tu dois
lui en vouloir comme ça mais bonjour me
paraît cher ami monsieur justin beiber
vous tombez bien expliqué à casimir
qu'une formule de politesse est
obligatoire à la fin d'une laine c'est
l'évidence même mon beau casimir vous
auriez plus haut - veut dire bonjour
c'est vrai je te prie de m'excuser pour
mais de toute façon je ne mettrai pas de
formules de politesse temps mal être
mais c'est indispensable casimiro tu
peux mettre quelque chose de très
élégant comme je vous prie de bien
vouloir agréer mon cher oncle
l'expression de mes sentiments très
distinguée très dévoué qu'en pensez vous
c'est cette élégance et respectueux et
ça fait très bien la fin de lettre
si je m'étais salle la formule serait
trois fois plus longue que la lettre à
vous n'avez rien de plus simple le sucre
est bas ce pauvre casimir ne peut se
permettre toutes les formules
habituelles que les gens de ma qualité
des niamey trop bas d'une lettre
casimir ainsi tu écrivais oui accepté
cheyrou mais respectueux zonage mais
voyons voyons françois alors les
hommages c'est réservé aux dames
ah oui c'est vrai que c est moi ce n'est
via l'avs ou simple mais cela me semble
suffisant pour l'ong l'arche iban
enfin je ne vois pas pourquoi vous vous
casser la tête je ne mettrai pas de
formules de politesse sans faille il
faut pas une autre j'ai trouvé accepté
gérant khl l'expression de ma tendre
affection si c'est très bien
on attendra fiction à mon avis c'est
parfait casimir constitue non non non et
non
[ __ ] j'y viens de soit pas cité q
pourquoi ne veux tu pas mettre une
formule de politesse à ton nom kharchi
bal mené laissez moi parler ça perd un
quart d'heure que j'essaie de vous
l'expliquer tenir leur ai dit que nous
mais bien voilà à la fin de sa lettre
mon oncle archibald
mais chris rock bruce archibald est un
vieux casimir us bourru et il met en fin
de lettre n'oublie pas n'oublie pas en
me répondant que j'ai horreur des
formules de politesse à
[Musique]